Do you use any navigation application to go through traffic jams?
What happens when you scroll down through your social media feed?
Do you follow any recommendation that any streaming service might give you?
So by the end of the day, we know that AI is there, but do we actually understand what
is going on, and can we trust the output of those applications?
To date, the approach that we've taken to these kinds of technologies is to say, well,
consumers can figure this out on their own.
They can read the terms and conditions on websites.
They can choose not to participate in certain digital environments, but increasingly, these
products and platforms are part of our lives.
They are part of the way that we provide education.
They are part of the way that we look for jobs.
And that power imbalance cannot be addressed by simply giving consumers more information
or giving them individual rights of complaint.
What we're ultimately going to have to do if we're going to change the kind of structural
ways in which these technologies are designed is to push the responsibilities back on our
designers, back on the organizations who are relying on technologies to change their practices.
Technologies like artificial intelligence have the potential to empower people and to
broaden their perspectives, or they can widen inequalities and really don't contribute to
address our societal challenges.
But we cannot blame the technologies.
It's not about the technologies.
It's about us developing the framework, shaping the rules that will allow these technologies
to deliver to what we want them to achieve.
And we need to make sure that we embed those very important ethical principles, the protection
and promotion of human rights and human dignity that will at the end determine the outcomes.
Responsible governance of AI technologies without the buy-in of Big Tech and other companies
is impossible.
It is necessary for us to find ways in which to explain to them that ethics is not about
abstract principles.
Ethics should be bottom up.
It is a dynamic system.
It should enable innovation and in the end lead to trust in products of these companies
which would lead to success in terms of whatever their business aims are.
We see how ethical debates end up playing an important role in shaping the conversation
of AI regulation over the last five years.
We saw a plethora of charters, declarations of AI ethical principles.
We are seeing right now that those principles are being applied on a very practical basis.
A lot of countries in Latin America have already come up with their national strategies on artificial intelligence.
But some countries in the region are going a step further.
They are actually regulating through hard law some of the principles of artificial intelligence.
In the European Union, we're looking at draft AI acts.
In the US, Congress is starting to talk in great detail about monopoly power of technology companies.
And you can see the wheels turning across the world as countries move from awareness-raising
to strategy, to attempts at implementation, attempts at regulation.